pendant parfois du côté recevoir il faut
que débuta et y'aura pénalité vous avez
vu qu'ils attendent étaient dures contre
la remplacer par ceux relevés au au
penny blement et ça c'est parce que
pacioretty s'est fait accrocher
et c'est très inquiétant pour sa
koulikov pour obstruction et pacioretty
mais pas jouer au devin l'armée
semble
un peu perdu
en
regardez bien c'est une mise en échec de
koulikov directement contre pacioretty
regardez c'est lorsqu'il tombe à la
renverse les cieux de la collision
pacioretty n'a jamais eu la rondelle l'a
évidemment
et là je
j'essaie de voir on essaie de trouver un
angle et donne lourdement le côté gauche
tito pacioretty dordonne lourdement
contre la bande ne semble pas y avoir de
contact entre la tête là pendant la
surface glacée ou qu'il donne lourdement
contre dame